all right simple and easy draft for
Monday's edition of PFT live AFC East a
decision we talked about earlier in the
program regarding what they need to do
by way of getting new players via the
draft who are the best players in the
AFC East that's what we'll draft now
Chris I have the trivia question if you
get it right you get the first pick with
Tom Brady gone from the division who is
the current quarterback in the AFC East
with the best career record against AFC
East teams well I mean that's gotta be
hold on I'm just want to make sure I'm
not missing anybody I mean I would think
that has to be Brian Fitzpatrick
wha-wha-wha Fitzpatrick is 17 and 26
against AFC East teams the current
quarterback with the this is a tough one
too this is far from what Keller is blue
Brian Hoyer is the right answer
Brian Hoyer is 12 and 5 against teams of
the AFC East so it was a little bit of a
trick question
yeah I know what he I did think of I
just didn't realize he had played that
many games against the AFC East that's
where I kind of chickened out I had a
feeling it was some sort of curveball
question like that and yeah thank you
for that that was very nice on a Monday
morning I appreciate that
Josh Allen is underwater at four and six
Fitzpatrick 17 and 26 Sam Donald three
and six against the AFC East the
Patriots have something to do with that
all right I get the first pick this
one's easy
the reigning Defensive Player of the
Year comes from the AFC East Stephon
Gilmore he spent his whole career in the
AFC East and I remember when he became a
free agent a few years ago when he was
with the Buffalo Bills after his rookie
contract expired and there was all the
speculation to bears the Eagles this
team that team and then BOOM the
Patriots grabbed him if you were like
Patriots why the Patriots like well this
one's easy they've dealt with the guy
for five years twice a year if they if
they're making the move they see
something in there that is more special
than what Stephon Gilmore has done in
his first five years and that's exactly
what is done during his time with the
New England Patriots Chris there was
actually talking at one point last year
of Gilmore for MVP early on when that
defense was reminding people the 85
Bears ultimately Defensive Player of the
Year so in the division yeah I think
that's
you're safe to say that for sure that
would have been my number one pick I
mean a this day and age the NFL the
cornerback the cornerback position all
the great receivers and quarterbacks and
everything like that and we know Bill
Belichick likes to put his guys in an
island like that he has tremendous
pressure on him on a week-to-week basis
yes and he was phenomenal after slam
dunk
you know NFL defensive MVP and I don't
think he's the best even I'm still
saying Aaron Donnell is the best
defensive player in football okay but
Stephon Gilmore at least is in that
conversation and that Patriots defense
was awesome last year all right
my pick I'm gonna go with Jamal Adams of
the New York Jets Jamal Adams for my
money is the best safety in the game
right now I mean he can do it all
whether that's you know tackle at the
line of scrimmage linebacker coverage
whatever it may be
blitzing creating plays running sideline
to sideline open field tackling I mean
he's really got it all I mean Jamal
Adams is a really really awesome
football player you know do the Jets
probably wish he would be maybe a little
more quiet with the microphones in front
of his face sure maybe but either way
for an organization that hasn't had much
life as of late you know Jamal Adams is
you know just a phenomenal football
player he really is and to me I don't
know Mike I don't know how you feel but
I think he is the best safety in the
sport right now all around yeah
absolutely he's an incredible talent I
think the push and pull with the Jets is
just trying to get him to buy in all in
all the time just rated by losing you
know he's got a little bit of that
Stefon Diggs quality to him where you
know takes a little care in feeding a
little temperamental and every once in a
while it flashes and I think that in his
heart of hearts he would like to be
traded to a winning team that he just
doesn't have faith that the Jets are
gonna put the kind of franchise around
him that's gonna help him have the kind
of success that he wants to have and
yeah it doesn't say a whole lot for the
division that the first two picks our
defensive players and my list has a lot
more defensive players and I thought
about going with a defensive newcomer to
the division Chris but yeah I'm gonna
I'm gonna make you pay for passing on
your guy Josh Allen in round one and
I've taken him off the board you
in there it's still a quarterback driven
league he's the best quarterback in the
division we saw him begin to come into
his own last year he's got the potential
to be a special talent for the Buffalo
Bills and I think he's the third best
player in the division right now yeah
that's fair I mean he's a game changer
he has game-changing type talents yeah
that's what you're saying you know his
arm is special you know is he need a
little work on accuracy and consistency
still sure yes but again we've seen two
years of incredible incredible athletic
ability and just elite traits from a
player let alone his ability to scramble
around extend plays run for yardage you
know do all of those types of things
quarterback design runs are a part part
of the equation so yeah I'm with you
Josh Allen for sure is I think it's a
budding superstar in in football right
now and a guy I would say watch out for
now that he's got Stefon Diggs all right
good pick by you I'm gonna go with
Devante Parker wide receiver for the
Miami Dolphins I mean as we sit here in
that last year from last year I mean
this was the best receiver in the
division for sure I mean Devante Parker
sized route running ability can beat you
down the field with go routes I mean we
saw saw what he did at the end of the
year week 17 against that Stephon
Gilmore in that great secondary for the
New England Patriots he kind of took
over the football game in the second
half of that one you know to me this is
a top-tier receiver in the NFL who's
battled a lot of injuries early on in
his career but last year was healthy and
showed you what he's all about Mike I
mean you know I've had him on my list
and I was a guy let me look at Devante
Parker stats 72 receptions for twelve
hundred and two yards okay nine
touchdowns sixteen point seven yards per
catch he was fifth in me in the NFL with
total yards altogether you know that's
that's dangerous right there to me yes
he's the best receiver in the division
so yeah if you're telling me is what
you're telling me is you would trade a
first-round pick a fifth round pick and
a sixth round pick this year and a
fourth round pick next year to get
Devante Parker's that were you telling
me I'm well I you know I would like to
see him stay healthy for one more year I
mean that's the difference but I think
his high end top end talent is
better than Stefon Diggs yes I do you
know and you know I love Diggs but he's
never consistently demonstrated I mean
you know all this I think this comes up
from time to time when we do it others
do it well if he could stay healthy well
but he he doesn't stay healthy
that's part of who you are you can't
stay healthy at the NFL level well maybe
it's not a knower I mean he was healthy
for 16 games last year so you know I
don't know maybe he's out of the woods
there
all I know is if you asked me who was
better last year Devante Parker Stefon
Diggs now two years or three years ago
when it doesn't freaking matter cuz that
was two or three years ago last year
Devante Parker was better than Stefon
Diggs is that my argument and tell Pete
him a little little itis to stop texting
me
I know Stefon Diggs is on the board I
cooked a bad day Parker have a stats
that actually texted that 100 you do
stats at home thank you thank you for
leaving my guys to fajn Diggs on the
board I'll make sure when we have him at
assuming there is a Super Bowl next year
because who knows at this point and
assuming that we're able to go there and
actually interview people when we have
Stefon Diggs I'm gonna make sure I point
out that back April we had to draft to
the best players of division and Sims
pick Devante Parker / Stefon Diggs but
yeah Diggs you know for all the reasons
we've discussed since the Vikings traded
him to the bills Diggs is a special
talent Diggs is the reason why Bills
fans should be very excited and Diggs is
one of the reasons why we're gonna see
Josh Allen get even closer to his
ceiling Diggs will run the route Alan
Dudley Digges will catch the ball Diggs
will be happy Bills fans will be happy
that we jump it through tables and doing
all the things Bills fans do and they
may very well take over the division
yeah I mean listen again I'm not gonna
like sit here and go oh gosh yeah you
know out there you dig this awesome I'm
with you I'm just telling you there's a
reason Devante Parker was a top 20 pick
and there's a reason he did what he did
last year without a Dalvin cook or a
Kirk Cousins or an Adam feeling across
from him to help him out it was him or
nobody else for that audello Dolphins
offense and he delivered last year and
that's why I'm on with him over them but
I still love Stefon Diggs what's up
Stefon you the man I still like you a
lot screw Floria okay alright watchin
you really no absolutely there's no way
and tweet out that you're watching
although else to watch right now I mean
we're the only live football show in the
mornings and we have been for the past
few weeks other than the week we're off
but Stefan if you're watching let us
know on Twitter we love you and I picked
you I would have picked you over to
Vontae Parker but Chris wouldn't
all right who's your third-round pick
this is a tough one here I'm gonna go
with your day be Aswath I am I'm gonna
go with today vyas Wyatt I think he is
uh he's a phenomenal football player
listen he could play man zone he tackles
he's smart you know he is certainly in
that conversation from one of the
premier corners in all of football you
know I don't think he's as athletically
gifted as a guy like Byron Jones but man
we can week out your davyous white could
do it all you know there's a lot of good
defensive players would you start to
realize that this division you know we
didn't see Jay Mosely JC Jackson you
know this Byron Jones Xavier Howard all
of those guys but I think I'll give the
extra davyous white right now he was at
all-pro last year and like I said he can
really do it all it was one of the best
players on one of the best defenses at
all a football so you know in hindsight
and we have to go here but maybe the
most concerning aspect of this draft for
the New England Patriots they had one
out of six players on the dirt yeah yeah
but they they got a lot of other players
that I think are right on the fringe
like when you get to JC Jackson like
Julian Edelman I thought about taking of
course Devin McCourty is in that
conversation you know there's you know
the that way I thought about them in a
lot of ways but yes I don't know if they
have the elite elite players that we're
talking about
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports